yes indeed this will twist your dusty
brain he's the unlikely YouTube
sensation who's inspiring a generation
to embrace matths Eddie woo brings the
magic back into matths he's a teacher
whose online lessons have been seen more
than 120 million times and in his new
book he hopes to demystify the world of
stem welcome back to Studio
10 year 12 exams are underway as we
speak what's been the feedback you're
getting on this year's maths exams from
students yeah look I'm I know there's so
much stress and anxiety that come come
up with those kinds of times of year but
to be honest it's a little bit like
getting on stage for a drama performance
all that stress leads into a high
performance so the feedback I've been
getting from kids is actually they're
pretty happy with how they exam oh
that's good it's good to get some
positive feedback uh my issue uh is that
I am not very good at math but I need to
teach my children math so how do parents
teach children's math when they don't
know math well just what I would say is
that makes you absolutely normal the
rest of us and even as someone who is
math trained myself I remember when the
pandemic put us all in remote learning I
was thinking to myself my kids are
primary age oh I have some things to
learn here and actually that's probably
my key piece of advice we want to be
Learners alongside our children we don't
need to be the experts but we need to be
patient with them and say okay maybe you
can help me learn something here too and
Eddie always helps us to learn and
you've got this new book as well which
it kind of takes us into the classroom I
suppose is it uh got a whiteboard which
as well which always puts me on edge
what are you going to teach us though
well Tristan don't stress because today
I want to talk about uh STEM Science
technology engineering and Mathematics
that's kind of the topic of the book and
stem's all around us it builds our
modern world so I kind of wanted to give
you a bit of an example of that would
that' be okay here You' got want some
props with me so this is just a simple
basketball and what I want you to pay
close attention to cuz Jess you're going
to help me here is what path does the
ball Trace as it moves through the year
just watch it you know you can see it
kind of has this how would you describe
this shape what what kind of shape is
the ball tracing as it moves yeah very
good an arc so have been great at ARC
has a special mathematical name we call
it a parabola very good so this is the
kind of shape you get now this is the
kind of shap the book type you're the
type of girl like copy traced under the
the force of gravity but this isn't the
only shape that gravity can make for
example if you ever think about say the
moon going around the earth obviously
not to scale it very roughly makes a
circular kind of orbit right so you're
like we've seen this kind of thing
before last little shape I want to
expose you to is if you think about the
sun right um you guys know what comets
are right so H's comet is a famous one
that comes around every 780 years it
doesn't make a parabola doesn't make a
circle it makes kind of this long sort
of shape this sort of stretched out
thing we called an ellipse you can only
see how these Comet when it's on this
side when it's near the sun that's why
it comes around every now and then now
these shapes Parabola a circle and
ellipse they look like they're kind of
so separate but Jess would you mind
helping me with this little prop over
here yes because actually all these
shapes are bound by one idea so this is
a cone here and you can see if you slice
across the cone you can see that
cross-section there you get the ellipse
right and if we if we cut right across
the top we would get a circle and then
if you want to just go get that other
cone
there you're so don't try and get be the
teach favorite I've
got can help you with thatp there um and
if you hold up this one here in red you
can see the shape that's there is it's
this Parabola shape you get all three
shapes from this one cone now this is
just one of the examples of how math is
part of Science and exploring all those
ideas is what the book's all about you
were just fabulous the way that you
teach and explain and you know yeah my
brain doesn't hurt as much as it used to
in Math's class amazing don't get that
actual physical pain awesome did youing
was remembering all the words what are
they called again that's an ellipse that
one and that's a PR all together we call
them conic sections because they cut a I
feel like if you if you just see
remember you know what you were saying
and then repeat the second word it looks
like you know
itronic section section oh this is
wonderful Eddie Woo's new book The
Wonderful World of stem is out now looks
absolutely brilliant I think everyone
should grab a copy of this we love
having you on the show Eddie thank you
so much for coming always a pleasure